Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
There are many AI techniques that are able
to look at a still image, and identify objects,
textures, human poses and object parts in
them really well.
However, in the age of the internet, we have
videos everywhere, so an important question
would be how we could do the same for these
animations.
One of the key ideas in this paper is that
the frames of these videos are not completely
independent, and they share a lot of information,
so after we make our initial predictions on
what is where exactly, these predictions from
the previous frame can almost always be reused
with a little modification.
Not only that, but here you can see with these
results that it can also deal with momentary
occlusions and is ready to track objects that
rotate over time.
A key part of this method is that one, it
looks back and forth in these videos to update
these labels, and second, it learns in a self-supervised
manner, which means that all it is given is
just a little more than data, and was never
given a nice dataset with explicit labels
of these regions and object parts that it
could learn from.
You can see in this comparison table that
this is not the only method that works for
videos, the paper contains ample comparisons
against other methods and comes out ahead
of all other unsupervised methods, and on
this task, it can even get quite close to
supervised methods.
The supervised methods are the ones that have
access to these cushy labeled datasets and
therefore should come out way ahead.
But they don’t, which sounds like witchcraft,
considering that this technique is learning
on its own.
However, all this greatness comes with limitations.
One of the bigger ones is that even though
it does extremely well, it also plateaus,
meaning that we don’t see a great deal of
improvement if we add more training data.
Now whether this is because it is doing nearly
as well as it is humanly, or computerly possible,
or because a more general problem formulation
is still possible remains a question.
I hope we find out soon.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!